antenne 2 et philips vous présente le
bar de la plage
l'émission d'été 2-1 dix ans
[Musique]
le vieux piano delà plein le jour
console quand solitude vieux pianos de
la place à des clients dont l'habitude
de danser
dimanche les autres jours ça sur les
planches dans la mer qui se souvient il
rêve son fait mais c'est alors le sens
de courbatures de ma cachette
et puis soudain de rang tremblante et
mis en lui charrette mais c'est à nous
tous que je retrouve comme cette musique
joli mais proulx me fait du mal
me fait du bien l'ancêtre adieu adieu
piano bonsoir bienvenue au bar de la
plage avec que jacqueline boyer au prix
roger nimier monsieur n'avoue jamais pas
se confie dans ce creuset de provence
leurs goûts leurs cours bref tout la
plage à la page
andré bercoff ivres de livres les
aventures de lolo chez les blaireaux du
bord de l'eau très chaud pour les petits
marie leurs actions de maryse et le
barman qui ne l'ouvrent qu'à bon escient
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
staline d'année
tél
non
[Musique]
steria com
pourquoi
oui
car si
salut
tél
m
il
l'hystérie
[Musique]
m
à
et
saleh
avant
[Musique]
de mon baladeur cd films répondu en
tapant 36 15 go daddy à la question
suivante qui a écrit la chanson ou et
vous jamais
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
didon jacky êtes très fine france
finalement c'est normal monsieur je suis
arménien vous faites un collègue dorian
colette renard
cette ligne françois 1 jacqueline boyé
m
on
et vous voudriez que ça s'appelle
autrement qu'un pascal souvent monsieur
non le vieux piano de la plage ne joue
qu'en faire quand fatigué le vieux piano
de la plage possède un là qui n'est pas
gay ainsi cassé qui se désole un lift
année qui le console ados brûlé par
grand soleil
dix mois de juillet
mais quand ils jour pour moi les airs
anciens que je préfère un frisson
d'autrefois en porte alors dans
l'atmosphère d'un grand bonheur dans une
petite chambre
mon grand amour du mois dis-moi oui tu
te souviennes tes vacances dans le
finistère chez sa grand mère c'est pas
chez ma grand mère se fait avec ma
grand-mère loctudy un petit village du
finistère ça se passe et j'avais 6 7 ans
ça a été très bref c'est très joli et
serge garde un bon souvenir puis après
ça va vite très vite dévié vers le
centre de la france qui sont là mes
vraies vacances d'enfance dans le
limousin près de traits d'image son
limousin mon limousin oui voilà c'est le
petit citadin qui jouent aux paysans
quoi dans le limousin
j'aimais beaucoup les étables j'aimais
beaucoup les cochons j'aimais beaucoup
les canards je vais préparer la pâte et
pour les cochons
oui j'aimais beaucoup ça avec mon oncle
il préparait les pommes de terre ça
sentait très bon et on mangeait à
l'époque les pommes de terre contre les
cuire dans du sel dans la pâte et les
cochons je me souviens de ça c'est un
rituel on mettait espèce de servir de la
sueur de bois on malaxe et c'est avec
les mains j'étais très content que ce
cérémonial et j'ai beaucoup aimé j'aime
la ville j'ai un bon équilibre avec la
campagne et quand je pense à la campagne
c'est forcément à la campagne de mon
enfance c'est à dire là et à partir de
l'âge de 10 ans à peu près ça a commencé
à aller dans les bals dans les bals de
campagne à écouter l'accordéon oui et
c'est là que j'ai appris ce goût pour la
pour la vraie chanson quoi on appelait
ça la frairie ça portait le nom de des
fêtes locales dans cette région est en
effet ce dont ça se passait dans les
années 60 quoi et on est payé mais des
balles très charmant avec des gens qu'on
tanguay je passais une image de
fraternité de l'été avec le son de
l'accordéon qui symbolise pour moi une
sorte d'amitié de ces gentilles assez
gai de quelle chanson
vient de l'époque dans ses balles avec
l'accordéon les premières chansons à
l'époque c'était j'ai quitté mon cher
pays la da du mérite à 10 da da da da da
da détruire corrèze dire est d'accord
c'est la mémoire du revers au vert mais
c'est vrai c'est formidable forme ird et
que dès que je peux chanter sale après
midi à la télévision
une fois de temps en temps la france
s'écroule en larmes on remet de bonheur
c'est bien il n'en faut aussi des dix
mois alors après il ya eu bessines
vous voyez tout on père tenait un bar
tabac il a mon père a été élevé dans ce
bar tabac et j'ai vu j'ai vu apparaître
là alors je retournais chez la tante qui
avait élevé mon père et j'ai vu
apparaître le premier tout box donc 59
alors là vraiment ça a été j'ai tu resté
collé devant ce qui se passait c'est que
tu es des donc dans le bar et en échange
de quoi tu avais des pièces de 20
centimes et puis alors tu l'aimés tu
évites dans le jukebox et écoutez quoi
emballer coup à l'époque on expliquer
alors vraiment les toutes premières
chansons de johnny hallyday les bonnes
plein de choses dès que les premières
bons souvenirs souvenirs de mon dossier
françoise hardy tout le première chance
il vit tous mes copains
alors je vois ça comme si j'étais on
écoutait aussi les dernières chansons
gloria lasso à l'époque mais oui parce
que c'était c'était très bizarre j'ai
lauriane et oui moi aussi c'était très
mélangée à l'époque johnny était une
jeune beurette loria souhaitait une star
dalida commencé très très on écoutait
bombe idowu on n'écoute pas les cloches
de lisbonne
on écoutait étrangères au paradis à
gloria lasso alors étrangers au paradis
vous en souvient romain
car je suis étrangère ici d'un avance
pays bleu étrangères au paradis ap ap ap
ap ap ap un très riche venus venus mon
ami
padilha
dans je suis pas les paroles mais elle
n'était pas génial non il y avait aux
vénus
les compagnons tous ont chanté dis donc
tu dis qu'à l'époque tous couché avec
ton transistors oui on est pressé alors
abbas et elle mérite sexuellement un
sexuellement c'était un bon début
c'est vrai que chez toi tu as 25 1010
25000 potter 7 est un peu beaucoup mais
en tout cas entre 15 et 20 milles sur
wii et alors tous ces disques voyais
étude va en amener un seul sur une île
des erreurs elle quelle question
impossible quand on en a quinze mille
mentalement impossible ce serait
peut-être peut-être une chanson de
lucienne delyle peut-être un air
d'accordéon jo privat une chanson de
trenet qui déjà je suis injuste parce
que des tas de choses que je vais
oublier ou comme ça je partage avec
renaud legoux pour une chanson qui
s'appelle mon amant de saint-jean à ces
gens qui n'aiment pas c'est moi qui
l'ait mettant mon bel avant mon amant de
saint-jean
un très joli un classique et je vais
faire ton éducation ah oui ça va me
prendre en main oui très sérieux c'est
vrai que tu as écrit pour dalida
il venait d'avoir 18 ans oui ça c'est
pas de l'intox - ça c'est la france à
celle d'un point c'est quoi les paroles
exactement il venait d'avoir 18 ans il
était beau comme un enfant un fort comme
un homme s'est elle était évidemment
j'ai compté en le voyant mes nuits
d'automne j'ai mis de l'ordre à mes
cheveux un peu plus de noirs sur mes
yeux ça la fait rire quand il s'est
approché de moi j'aurais donné n'importe
quoi pour le séduire ça finit tristement
parce qu'elle s'aperçoit qu'à la 2 x 18
ans et c'est quelqu'un qui est bien
connu les héros de la chanson relié à
l'époque oui oui sûrement
10dans c'est vrai que ton premier job de
vacances c'était garçon coiffeur je ne
crois pas ça absolument pas mais tu sais
quand on a 15 ans comme ça et qu'on dit
à sa mère et à son père qu'on veut être
écrivain chanteur star de je ne sais
quoi on vous dit il vaut mieux apprendre
un métier et ma mère qui n'est pas
stupide m'a dit que ce serait peut-être
bien tu coiffe les voisines et
apprennent un peu un métier et c'était
pas content du tout parce que ça m'a
beaucoup servi notamment service
militaire
ah bon ça t'a permis de ma part du
général ah oui c'était triste année
alors je veux tu es bien arrangé site
souvient de tes amours de vacances où il
fort ce forcément mais mes grands
souvenirs et ça va être terrible pour
toi ne sont pas sexuel alias et je sais
je suis un peu de jeu mais je sais
[Musique]
oh ça va
ah bah ouais c'est pas trop mal à la
jambe s'est abîmé voilà plus maintenant
ouais et le scooter et là vous avez mal
aussi
oh là là ou pas de chance bidon ci se
glissent là ici ben ouais bah écoute
aussi vous alliez à saint tropez l'hôtel
sont en vacances vous avez déjà quel
hôtel ou tel le provençal à baja c'est
là où je dois aller
oui j'ai gilbert et christine que vous
avez pris un petit vélo santé je suis
désolé on voit un whisky alors que tout
s'est passé aujourd'hui
on va écouter magna car ça c'était
journée que je retiendrai de votre
non mais vraiment j'ai eu un monde fou
et j'aurais fait le double avec vous je
vous avais bien à moi je vous emmène en
voiture ça va demain vous allez vous
aviez ou à bas je me baladais mais vous
êtes très mal à la cemac et boit du
whisky alors à
je peux vous faire voir d'autres
accédants même les chinois je vois même
chez vous jouez bien ce jeu vous va bien
sûr et puis je suis tout seul en plus en
ce moment alors je trop mignonne avant
ben oui vous êtes qu'elle est française
annonce canadienne canadienne avant oui
deux fois que je rivalise alors avec l
indienne ouais je sois chez moi il
justement il ya un grand dîner maillot
des adducteurs qui viennent tout le
monde qui sont charmants
[Musique]
tu dis quoi pendant les vacances je
m'éloigne un peu du roman parce que en
avançant dans la vie je trouve que tous
les jours la vie est plus fort ni alors
le style des grands écrivains bon bien
sûr quand je veux revenir un grand livre
des démos jeu banal ou des limiers des
trucs des six mis non je pense que c'est
en désordre voire mais l'élite politique
j'aime bien les pamphlets j'aime bien
aussi je viens de relire le joual de
claude mauriac récemment pas mal quand
même vrai j'aime bien ça à moi en
parlant de 10 me et tu as eu le prix
nimier
ça c'était vraiment c'était une des plus
grandes joies de thé view est la même
c'est normal
1 oui ça a été vraiment formidable
j'étais à jury magnifique et très fier
là je le porte vraiment comme gracieux
mais franchement tu penses pas que la
tête un peu choisi la facilité
parce que c'est très bien ce que tu
faisais moins 50 contenu une prime signé
avec les honneurs on à vichy dancing
aussi prospects aurait dû continuer sa
belle mère dirait vous êtes fous au
petit garçon mais parce que je pensais
que tu gâches un talent ben moi je me
laisse porter un peu aussi par la vie à
la vie passe très vite
la télévision c'est 2007 on est venu me
chercher ça s'est fait par un concours
de circonstance français partent à la
télévision je voulais écrire
peut-être un peu de radio mais bon c'est
la télévision qui est venu je me suis
pris au jeu
je me passionne car j'aime passionnément
la chanson et chaque jour je me dis mais
enfin faire tout ça en effet je pense
aussi à ça mais je ne suis pas
malheureux si j'étais malheureux
j'aurais arrêté
j'essaie de continuer de c'est
impossible j'écrirai un jour on est
toujours virer un jour ou l'autre de la
télévision donc ça s'arrangera entre
chaque moment où sera dirigé par yves
leterme chanson qui devient esprit là
comme ça je préfère la merde que reste
qui
de nos amours que reste-t-il de c'est
beau jour une photo vieille photo de ma
jeunesse
que reste-t-il des billets doux et mois
d'avril les rendez vous un souvenir
qui me poursuit sans cesse leurs
familles cheveux au vent des volets rêve
mouvant que reste-t-il de tout cela
dites le moi
1 au bord de l'eau comme ça le soir tu
es parfait
[Musique]
tiens
oh
[Musique]
vous savez ce que c'est qu'un l'api de
monsieur non j'attends c'est un clin qui
va très très vite
c'est nul mais pourquoi raconter vous
toujours des histoires de train je pense
que je n'ai ni l'humour ni permis de
conduire monsieur
[Musique]
alors jean bonsoir
qu'est ce que tu fais dans la vie je
suis viticulteurs ou à plus évident dans
le var tu as beaucoup d'hectares a pas
mal ça quand même non oui ça suffit je
suis ici pour gagner combien par mois
pas beaucoup c'est à dire très peu fait
pas chez le percepteur
non mais il peut écouter sait jamais
avant pour être riche est taclé quatre
là mais jamais au grand jamais qu'est ce
que tu fais comme 20 ben je fais du
côtes de provence mauvaise réputation
c'est les gens qui n'y comprennent rien
qui narre aussi ceux qui n'apprécient
pas la côte de provence où des gens qui
ne l'ont jamais goûté ou des gens qui
n'y comprennent rien
qu'est ce qu'il a de bien que de
provence à comment tu le vendre et on le
voit en le faisant apprécier devons
allons-y avec plaisir
voilà
et pour nous ça va
il est même au go voilà ça vieillissait
va pas très longtemps de deux ans
maximum
par contre les rouges ils seront alors
aujourd'hui le côtes de provence et
mauvaise image c'est dû à quoi est ce
pas toi ben une nouvelle information
départ ouais
et peut-être un passé qui n'a pas
toujours été le lien n'a pas toujours
été aussi bon que maintenant depuis dix
ans ont fait de gros efforts de qualité
on diminue le rendement pour kevin et
produisent ou moins sur mesure les
méthodes de vinification et échanger
améliorée je crois que maintenant on est
arrivé au top on se permet de gagner de
pas mal de médailles dans les concours
on est on est en principe et savez vous
combien une bouteille de côtes de
provence pour que les gens se fassent
trop arnaque et la littérature en
restaurant c'est à dire il ya un prix à
la production en plus dans la version 1
to et une faune combien ce domaine qui
vaut 17 francs 50 de la bouteille tâches
et ses investigations et en se
restaurant je peux le trouver à combien
se vend 70 kg championne sans quelques
fois et dis moi tu vois autre chose que
du code de prononcer je vois tous les
vins oui mais je bois tous les jours au
moins une bouteille de côtes aux droits
humains bouteilles d'ici là et ça te
fait quoi
ça fait du bien à bord de ce très bon
pasteur a dit que le vin était un
aliment ah bon oui et les campagnes anti
alcoolique ça devienne pas toi ça me
gêne beaucoup parce qu'elles sont très
mal faite
ils font des campagnes contre
l'alcoolisme en le faisant voir sur les
affiches et les télévisions que des
verts devaient alors que
raph et le pastis hoya de pastilla luiz
qui a les alcools l'étranger et alors on
a demandé à certains publiciste pourquoi
du vin n'est pas autre chose
il prétend de simplement que c'est parce
qu'un verre de vin rouge ressorts mieux
à l'écran ou sur la fiche kriss est dur
pour autant voilà c'est dur à tes
parents tes seins déjà mes parents que
de ses grands parents aussi
mes grands parents aussi c'est une
tradition familiale oui et j'espère que
la descendance pendant la suite ça se
passe comment la vie pour toi ça se
passe bien le matin par exemple de l
acquéreur mais ça dépendra saison oui
disons qu'on a tendance à se lever avec
le jour voilà sûrement ses cinq rivaux
le matin en temps normal lorsque l'été
est un véritable hit et pas comment
cette année on travail de cinq heures à
midi s'est bien combiné au fait la
sieste quand même ah oui quand même
récupérer ce que assuré de rater un et
alors sinon tu vas le soir tu vas voir
des copains comment ça se passe non
c'est plutôt les copé qui viennent me
voir là et là alors quelquefois beau du
passé et quand tu vois quand tu vois
arriver les parisiens étaient en pense
quoi alors c'est difficile à dire parce
que oui bah disons que les parisiens ils
sont formidables conditions pas chez eux
riche idée sympa qui la ramène pas non
pas trop
mais tandis que canal a choisi sont et
supporte une autre est de cul terreux
bon surtout dans les rues de paris
qu'elle nettoie la nano voiture
immatriculée 83 c'était différent
puis l'accent c'est tout de suite par
action
le notre bonheur tu regrettes quoi la
provence d'avant là je regrette
on n'y a rien à regretter ce qu'on peut
regretter c'est que que la provence
notre terre ce soit urbanisées peut être
un peu vite et un peu maladroitement
on a vu du béton partout mais ça c'est
le foot c'est vous qui habitez ici sinon
qu'il avait laissé faire ça chez nous c
nous puisons il ya des gens qui ont
maintenu des terrains une passe à la
suite d'événements familiaux des
familles qui s'arrêtaient de travailler
la terre ou autres qui ont maintenu puis
les personnes et que d'acheter ont
revendu à des promoteurs ne peut pas
arrêter la chose toute façon il faudrait
sur la maîtrise et la provence elle
existe encore elle existe encore
certainement si tu devais définir la
provençale c'est quoi pour toi
[Musique]
la mas provençal c'est l'accueil
l'amabilité
l'amitié qu'on essaie de faire partager
et de recevoir on donne beaucoup et même
en novembre et puis peut-être la
décontraction mais pas autant que ce que
les parisiennes faute a dit que les
parisiens quand ils disent que une
sardine qui a bouché le port de
marseille ce fou de la gueule des
provençaux à cause de ça je sais que
c'est pas vrai ils n'ont rien compris
ils n'ont rien compris c'est un fait
véridique qui s'est passé le port de
marseille
une petit emprunt comme mesure de porc
jour est un bateau qui s'appelait la
sardine qui a coulé dans le port à ses
slams square alors la sordide a bouché
le port de marseille
et là ça a suffi pour que les
parisiennes 10 alors que nous exagérons
en tout cas un peu vrai mais toujours et
ils ont bien vu que c'était une sordide
et qui avait lâché le morceau beaucoup
de choses comme ça sur la provence qui
sont racontées qui sont pas mal aussi
pour votre tonique
les provençaux se lève à midi pour au
bar le pas si ces jours au boulot c'est
faux ils ont fait leur bonheur seulement
les parisiens qui sont à ma case qui ne
se lève à 15h30 ne nous voit qu'à
l'heure du pas si c'est de la pétanque
je crois qu est ce que tu leur dirai aux
parisiens qui viennent en vacances l'été
dans le var en provence je leur dis avec
wall a promené à mieux nous connaître
vous êtes prêts à les rencontrer
on va bien sûr oui devant un verre de
rosé ou plusieurs verres de rosé
voilà
[Musique]
monsieur vous êtes chez moi chez vous et
vous le savez merci mais permettez-moi
monsieur d'être dépités
je vous permets mais dépêchez vous faute
avouée est à moitié pardonnée n'est ce
pas c'est à moi qui veux dire le
contraire les gays alors le guy mardel
que vous prétendez recevoir ce soir
jeunes affirme-t-il pas haut et fort
qu'il n'avoue jamais
j'attends vos explications monsieur
20 mai
jamais jamais jamais jamais
que même la neige
non jamais baboo jamais que
[Musique]
si tu veux qu'on te donne ce que tu
attends
si tu veux que l'automne
et le boom du printemps
ça celui des routeurs
et souvient totaux jeu
qu'il faut semer le doute
porical
là mais jamais
jamais jamais
[Musique]
non non jamais jamais que
c'est une tueuse défendre tout puzzle
tu tiens entendre les plus tendres
celui que l'on aime
ceux qui ne
il commence un poème
même fini tard
là
car j'en ai
jamais jamais
jamais google lui-même n'a jamais jamais
jamais ben vous jamais que
là
[Musique]
jamais
jamais un bain ou la mer
que
il a
[Musique]
jamais je n'ai jamais là vous jamais que
tu là
c'est lourd à porter segura c'est
encadré cette chanson démarre dès 1965
1966 et brière qui a écrit cette chanson
je l'écris tge qui la musique et ses
promesses de rennes qui a écrit les
paroles
françoise dorin way back grande
françoise dorin oui et cette année un
beau doublé parce qu'elle ait fait ma
bouche années et que c'est triste venise
pour la zone euro et la création s'est
passé comment ces cartes a fait la
musique toi d'abord et ensuite lui
apporter la musique non non non c'est à
dire que moi je travaille je travaille
avec des auteurs que
que paul lederman qui était mon
imprésario de 7 et paul lederman a
d'ailleurs trouvé un peu faible et il
voulait que je travaille avec les
personnes et il m'a dit qu'il ya une
nana qui fait des textes de chansons tu
devrais aller la voir et je suis allé la
voir
et a priori elle était aussi intimité
que moi et elle m'a donné un certain
nombre de textes en disant oh là j'étais
texte que j'ai déjà écrit la musique de
ce si vous voulez prendre
puis j'en ai pris trompe la supporter
merci madame j'avais 19 ans en fac de
droit
et puis je suis gémissait texture mon
piano et c'était c'est à peu près trois
quatre mois avant les
les examens de fin d'année et de temps
en temps entre deux cours de droit civil
commercial je m'étais devant le piano et
puis un jour je tombe sur ce texte et je
crois que la chanson mais il était resté
dix quinze jours sur sur ce piano comme
ça je le regarde et excel et au bout de
un quart d'heure vingt minutes ce jour
là la chance n'était fini or j'ai senti
que j'ai senti qu'il y avait quelque
chose d inspiration ouais mais c'est
sorti comme ça j'ai appelé françois l
écouter la chanson devient aussi bien
oui c'est bien et puis et oui mais avant
même avant qu'un tube sur les t-bonds
cgem non c'est pas vrai comme a vendu
combien en parlant de tubes ont tous
parce que maintenant ça continue avant
même que l'on doit être 3 millions 10,3
millions de disques c'est de rapporter
un maximum et moi tu as commencé à avoir
cette idée comme ça de d'écrire des
chansons qu'en dehors 18 19 ans et pas
avant sinon on était petit bain donc
j'avais fait chez des parents quand
quand il comptait tout petits une petite
école un violon dans l'est dans l'est
dans les formats et monfils traviole
hanister médecins surtout les parents
pieds noirs ici par violoniste et
médecins il a joué du violon il sera
médecin
en fait j'ai pas été longues parce que
j'ai cassé le violon je ne pouvais pas
supporter certains instruments et puis
donc je me suis mis à faire du piano
est ce que ta mère était contente au
moins ouais mais enfin le temps était
content une condition c'est que je
finisse mes études je voulais pas que
j'arrête
donc j'ai promis ça j'ai tenu ma fête et
bien après quand tu as fait n'est jamais
tout ça il s'est contenté et après
n'avoue jamais t'as fait quoi alors il
ya eu tous pendant trois ans des
tournées en france avec le françois et
puis après j'ai eu la chance comme on le
sait en france et malgré claude françois
arrêtons nous fait tourner ça se passe
et comment alors je crois que j'étais le
seul dans les tournées avec le bloc qui
ne savent qu'ils ne soient pas engueulé
avec ris parce que j'étais un petit peu
aussi en moi il fallait que je finisse
ma licence donc quand j'étais dans l'est
dans l'année dans l'est l'autre dans la
loge dans les coulisses moi je faisais
mais vous mettez des de droits qu'avant
j'avais pas trop l'occasion de
m'engueuler heures après donc ton avec
claude françois et après après comme je
vais représenter la france à
l'eurovision
on m'a demandé de représenter leur
présentent aux concours internationaux
alors j'ai fais le
j'ai représenté la france au festival de
barcelone concède de la chanson à
barcelone j'ai gagné j'ai fait le
festival de rio que j'ai gagné également
festival de tokyo
j'ai vu un prix de la critique et tout
ça ça m'a fait faire beaucoup beaucoup
de tournées pendant trois quatre ans à
l'étranger
oui mais c'est vrai ça parce que tu sais
que les chanteurs ils disent toujours
c'est moi je vends beaucoup au japon
c'est vrai quoi c'est ben non c'est vrai
que les gens perdent ici mais c'est vrai
quoi c'est justement très les coupures
de courant
écoutez on te croit mais alors après tu
es revenu en france après tout ces
tournées à l'étranger et on sait pas où
il va oui c'est ça à la rue et si vous
faire de sa non parce que je savais que
de toute façon ça se passerait comme ça
et j'ai comme j'ai toujours eu une
position vis-à-vis du métier qui est
malheureusement le ce métier devenu un
métier de hulu les rapports de force
sont très grands et calmement c'est dans
les années soixante dix et c'est devenu
de plus en plus aussi au fil des années
et maintenant c'est carrément un rapport
de mendiants on est complètement dément
lundi et se jouer c'est réussir ma vie
c'est pas mal comme dans le showbiz -
donc je pars contre chanter pour moi
c'est un besoin vital je dirais pas que
c'est un truc qu'on dit quand on n'a pas
réussi ça je voulais réussir ma vie
non parce que moi j'ai décidé de réussir
ma vie avant de penser à réussir dans la
chanson dont le problème ne soit posée
puisque j'ai managé ma vie on sera en
fonction de ça puisque j'aurais pu venir
en revenir en france et ramé comme les
autres copains sortir des disques moi
j'ai pratiquement jamais sorti le disque
qui n'a pas marché
ça fait sept ans que j'ai pas fait de
disque donc on peut pas dire mardaye
laramée pourrait faire débuter sa part
ça marchait plus non ça marche pas parce
que parce que je sortais de 10 mais elle
mais allez allez mais à l'époque
à l'époque j'ai une deuxième chance
après la rencontre avec françoise burel
jamais c'est que j'ai rencontré des gens
de télé dont certains savez que j'ai
plus très créateurs et que je que je
pouvait interférer la cheville au
tableau c'est guy lux à vous c'est que
drucker non non en entendant pendant
quatre ans donc j'ai fait de la télé
mais j'étais producteur d'une émission
télé et j'ai produit devant des
émissions dès samedi après midi que
chapeauter le luxe mais j'étais
producteur de mes émissions
j'ai produit d
des émissions sur l'a2 à 20h30 avec
annie cordy etc
et puis la dernière mission g est
produite c'était une émission qui
s'appelle sport en fête vérité mon
présentateur ah ben ouais c'est toi
qu'elle va trouver michel volcker non
c'est michel qui m'a téléphoné pour me
dire j'aime bien ton émission j'ai envie
d'y rentrer ah ouais à il est rentré et
moi j'en suis sortie s'il admet me l'a
demandé a pris la suite de l'émission
elle il ya beaucoup de talent et je lui
en veux plus donc michel larqué
l'émission moi je me suis retrouvé à la
rue j'avais deux enfants en bas âge il
fallait bien que je fasse quelque chose
donc je refais du disque tient les brawn
gp chez ibm et leur après tu as fait un
duo avec chantal goya c'est moins drôle
ça quand même parfois que l'on sait pas
peut-être que c'est a lancé c'est pas la
chose la plus fantastique que j'ai fait
est ce que tu penses que toute cette
époque c'est des tentatives de come back
un peu échoué ou tu faisais ça comme ça
un peu sur le côté quoi ça
non c'est à dire que je si si pour moi
il était question de dire 'est-ce que tu
préfère ne pas vendre que de vendre des
millions de disques je dis je préfère
vendre des millions de disques c'est
évident et je les ai pas vendu mais je
les ai pas vendu pour quelles raisons
c'est que je n'ai jamais voulu nous
compromettre ou compromettre mon moi
intime c'est à dire que je jusque je
veux bien aller jusqu'à un certain point
les mains je n'ai plus mes pas me
regarder dans une glace et me dire tu es
minable surtout là parce que c'est pas
toi mais qu'est ce que t'es pas prêt à
faire alors présente dans ce métier
qu'est ce que tu es pas prêt à faire
soit entendre on dirait quand même que
c'est une prostitution perpétuelle
qu'est-ce que tu n'es pas prêt à
demander aux attachés de presse ouais
c'est pas les artistes et appelle les
présentateurs ou les et producteur de
télévision s'est attaché de presse oui
c'est abb prenait l'eau dans votre
édition entre grunge pas ça non mais
c'est à dire que c'est parce que le à
une certaine époque j'ai produit
d'autres chanteurs il est donc je me
suis retrouvé comme
ah oui quand tu es devenu producteur
s'était énervé cd et demander quoi donc
j'étais bien obligé de dépenser plus
facile de défendre d'autres chanteurs et
se défendre soi même qu'à ce moment là
tu vas arrêter d'être producteur ces
derniers disent que j'ai produit j'ai
dit que j'avais été remonté un peu
inquiète jours enfin une entreprise de
gravure de disques a très bien marché
entre 84e 25 s'appelait master one c'est
ça y est on gagne de l'argent quand même
non l'action gagne de l'argent
finalement tu graver des disques en
vinyle et puis quand lazers est arrivé
tu avais soit le choix d'investir
énormément soin de laisser tomber tu as
laissé tomber est reparti vers de jouer
parce que c'est le challenge pour moi
était réussie donc je passais à autre
chose et j'ai j'avais quand même à cette
époque là où de nouveaux gros noms très
très envie de chanter
ouais alors comme j'avais plus de dix
qui ont un marché en phase iib opus plus
à richert n'avoue jamais c'est
introuvable d'ailleurs c'est ce que
c'est cher non elle ressortie à bord
ouais oui mais enfin parce que les
compilations dirait que ça qui marche en
ce moment puisque les délais les
programmateurs de radio où les maisons
de disques sont incapables de trouver
des nouveaux artistes il faut bien que
le que le métier vives de quelque chose
que cette industrie marche alors ils ont
trouvé les compilations cents à monter
un restaurant qui s'appelle le chorus
café alors jusqu'à 11 heures du soir
c'est un restaurant normal 11h bon ça
devient enchante crs de concerts sixties
tous les soirs vous chantez quoi jean
laurent vanat vous jamais toute la nuit
quand même bien tranchante les sixties
mais le [ __ ] si c'était il fort pour
se replacer dans le contexte de 86 quand
j'ai créé mon restaurant
quand j'ai dit à certaines personnes de
ce métier je vais monter un restaurant
on va chanter des chansons des années 60
a répondu moi tu étais fou ça fait
ringard les années 70 intéresse personne
moi je sentais que le public avait
besoin de ça tu crois que tu vas finir
dans ce cas baala dans ce restaurant
je crois pourquoi je crois pas que j'ai
envie de faire d'autres choix que faire
quoi accueillir des disques
dis moi ton avis pourquoi t'es pas
devenu une énorme star pourquoi
finalement tu vois tu as fait ta tubes
et vois t'as pas exploser complètement
parce que lorsque les journalistes de
france dimanche venaient me voir je
refusais de monter des coups par six
points suicide tue médéa
parce que parce que parce que je ne bois
pas d'alcool je veux dire je suis pas et
ça veut pas dire que je sois un triste à
dire mais je n'ai pas tout ce côté qui
favorise les rencontres à 2 heures du
matin et moment on va sûrement vous ma
part je suis pas ça et
et déjà et c'est plus petit croix non je
crois que je crois que c'est passé c'est
pas grave
[Musique]
m
rectifie dans l'eau après les dauphins
les orques et les baleines chaque année
des milliers de taris s'échouent sur les
plages
y'a pas moyen de les ranimer l'a1 a6
regardait la femelle bouge un peu encore
même enceinte stéphanie de monaco est
obligé de garder l'anonymat grâce à un
chapeau qui la protège des regards
indiscrets et portugais prend sécher
dans l'ain ici une petite culotte et une
grosse capote effiloché alors tu as
trouvé de club ton père quoi les applis
même pas pour mais ici je suis pas un
cherche
qu'est ce que vous mettez vos jumelles
des mecs vous regardez les regarder les
brâkmar des garçons avec les jumelles ah
non la région
tiens mon oeil la région la région des
testicules le bateau les petits bateaux
vous avez une petite réaction là vous
avez vu une petite érection la france
c'est le tour de france et les filles
comme regarder les filles voyez
l'antenne elle se déplie un peu alors
vous promener sur la plage mais vous
avez quand même importe capote
oui j'ai combien de capote dans le port
de capotes comme une gamine dans une
journée ici sur la côte
aucune j'ai passé là aucune je sais la
retraite monsieur est ce que vous êtes
qu'on appelle un amateur sur la plage
non pas du tout
je me prends même journée vous avez bien
noté combien de niche en moyenne non
nature comme ça aux pions et amateurs ni
groupés en est rien du tout qu'est ce
que vous regardez en premier chez une
fille bon dans l'ensemble un peu tout
l'âge d'or bob ou reçus à partir d'un
certain âge qu'on va regarder les plus
jeunes et vous êtes tiré comme une
mauvaise et puis vous êtes là déjà moi
je suis avec ma femme on leur note
on dit que dans un couple c'est l'homme
qui porte la culotte mais là visiblement
c'est pas le cas non outils métalliques
et le petit bonhomme tes amis ta culotte
et me répond quand je te cause assez
monsieur un peu dégarni est en train de
donner la vie à un super beau mâle de
couleur de 23 ans
c'est très très beau des images
magnifiques à les y pousser monsieur que
vous êtes là combien de mètres déjà
aucun mec vous êtes avez combien de
mètres des joueurs à une quinzaine
combien de mecs de joueurs
vous avez changé malheureusement pour
les grands-mères et heureusement pour
les déchets comme moi chaque année il ya
un grand super l'été eh bien cher dany
du marketing soyez heureux cette année
vous avez fait le carton please don't go
to value
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oui
non
quant aux messieurs
juncker
[Musique]
dans l'eau
mais
juli
un mouvement
ce moment
bingo
[Musique]
et
nous sommes
[Musique]
oh
m
amis lyonnais
[Musique]
non
m
tu peux
oh
[Musique]
jacky j'ai soif
moi aussi bien sûr avec du citron
la civilité n'est pas toujours une
qualité ni ses démos tous âges qui quand
je pense à tous ces gens qui pioche des
chiffres les moyennes des consoles et
tout ça pour quoi pour faire des démos
qui servent à team aqua à rien qu'est-ce
que vous avez ce soir jacky sais rien
j'ai une remontée d'entreprise c'est
quoi ça un mot
andré bercoff bonsoir les livres de la
semaine thierry odm wada douteraient
comprends-tu quelque chose aux femmes
non et bien moi non plus alors j'ai
voulu essayer de comprendre parce que
vraiment ça fait des années que je me
pose la question je me dis mais comores
comme on comprend comment ça fonctionne
comment arriver à quelque chose plus et
on a vraiment des problèmes je veux dire
la communication tu vois la parole
l'amour la drague et j'ai lu de livre
que je veux que je te conseille vraiment
de ligne là s'appelle la mécanique des
femmes de louis calaferte plus qu'à la
faire taire un excellent écrivain qui a
écrit le partage des vivants et il a
fait un bouquin je dois dire à mettre
entre toutes les mains
mais peut-être au-dessus de 13 en commun
quand même et il fait parler les femmes
du sexe de leur sexe de celui de leur
zone des rencontres des de l'amour et de
la sensualité de l'orgasme et dans les
termes les plus crus les plus forts
possibles et c'est formidable parce qu'à
aucun moment sur les photographies qu à
aucun moment c'est vulgaire chip etc
c'est je dirais des paroles crues comme
de la viande crue c'est à libre de
déchets mais au bon sens du terme c'est
lorsque tu as des steak au poivre
tu es le formidable mouvement daube puis
tu as des choses beaucoup plus sensuelle
beaucoup plus subtil mais qu'elle vient
mais quelle viande mais qu'elle les mots
chers et puis alors là tu entends ces
paroles de femmes qui en fait beaucoup
plus loin que tous les ans rémy l'air
les grands auteurs érotiques dont on a
parlé et ce sont des paroles qu'il a
recueillies au cours de sa vie amoureuse
et il les livre tout cru donc saignante
sans préservatif
totalement brut de décoffrage à nos yeux
est je crois maintenant que je commence
à comprendre quelque chose à savoir que
la femme est beaucoup plus sensuelle que
l'homme parce qu'elle est la terre parce
que la paire mer et que quand elle a
envie de parler et que quand les
sangsues s'en vont et des tabous s'en
vont et bien c'est un bagage mirifiques
c'est le cantique des cantiques c'est
salomon en femme
voilà ça s'appelle la mécanique des
femmes et ça veut pas dire que les
femmes sont des machines pas du tout
mais ça veut dire qu'on a un père est
vraiment vraiment vraiment à apprendre
et on ne mettra jamais de toute une vie
pour apprendre
très beau livre de louis calaferte
l'autre libre c'est un livre de
quelqu'un qu'on connaît bien c'est
philippe sollers
cet écrivain bordelais qui à mon avis
tâter du linge bajot d'idron parce que
vraiment à lui écrit un roman très beau
où il s'appelle d'ailleurs le héros
s'appelle carrément philippe diamant
quand on sait que lui s'appelle film
joyau dont il retourne abandon il
rencontre l'ancien petit ami et surtout
et surtout il parle de deux choisis par
littérature il parle politique c'est
sollers quand ici mais c'est formidable
parce qu'il n'arrête jamais il ya un
espèce de débile et de débit intéressant
et il parle aussi d'une jeune femme
suisse une jeune doctoresse qui
rencontre et cette doctoresse a pour
particularité décrire ces scénarios
érotiques et lui dit quand je te rends
compte aurais tu seras abeilhan blouson
ccir blouson cela nous ferons l'examen
je te dis pas de quoi mais tu peux
deviner
je serai l'infirmière goethe examinerait
cercle ensemble ils font des scénarios
j'ai pas si sollers l'a vécue ou pas et
lettres sont extrêmement suggestives et
la fille a une imagination mais alors je
te lis pas tous les métiers tous les
corps de métier les portes cochères les
ascenseurs les trains les avions les
coûts chaîne tout y passe
et à chaque fois avec un scénario alors
je vais te dire dean d'orson welles ou
de 34 ans et ça finit toujours de la
façon dont jouira quand je te le dirai
et je jurais quand je déciderai sert
qu'à chaque fois là c'est la femme qui
commande et lui l'écrivain et oui ravis
heureux contents de se retrouver enfin
prise en main au propre comme au figuré
par cette espèce de ds érotique qui
arbore ses lunettes avant de le regarder
et on sent que sollers là il s'en est
jamais remis portrait du joueur
un très beau livre pour jouer pendant
l'été
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
là
m
[Musique]
la beta
pas là
toi
bonsoir merci d'avoir passé cette soirée
avec nous au bar de la plage prochaine
ouverture samedi prochain salut bande de
nabeul
n'hésitez pas
[Musique]
quitte à dormir tu parles
ouais
brignone ita
[Musique]
pour tous
m
[Musique]
oh
lui si la mode est ouvert
[Musique]
le tout
l'état
[Musique]
non
quitter
[Musique]
au grand chez philips bar de la plage la
question est de tous a écrit la chanson
dont vous jamais et la réponse françoise
dorin
vous allez gagner le baladeur cd
phillips à télécommande programmation
possible jusqu'à 20 plages bravo
antenne 2 et philips vous ont présenté
le bar de la plage l'émission d'été de
thierry ardisson
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater
le lean a l'habitude abonnez vous il
m'était impossible eux